okay so this is Susan strong and boy oh
boy some big revelations on this one of
course the biggest one being that
Princess Bubblegum has even more clothes
did you see she wore two different
outfits this time unbelievable no oh
well that shit like all of us at open
one that is totally a revelation that
these characters actually change clothes
I guess a little bit forgot for me just
seeing all this stuff going on I'm like
what the hell what the hell is that like
that anything is like really open-ended
and like sort of uncomfortable in us in
a way and like it's bittersweet and I'm
like wow like I was actually like it's
it's one of the first times we're really
like yeah what is the story behind this
I mean you're we serve like in the bank
your head you're thinking y'all might be
fun just to know what's going on but
this is the first one that was like yeah
I really want to know I want to know the
story now they gave just enough intrigue
on that you know it just enough of a
clue and well okay very those don't know
or whatever had to be reminded this is
one where they find a shelter that's
underground and these people they're all
wearing like animal heads very similar
what Finn had on are down there and they
sort of kind of speak English but they
haven't spoken it in a while so they're
sort of learning this stuff again he
comes across one called Susan it was
just giant lady and introduces her to
the Candy Kingdom and she likes candy
lord knows they driving at anything
sweet for years and the poor peppermint
Buzzard yeah and she goes and she wants
to get other people to come and feed on
the place but then they fight him off
and they take off the animal hats and it
looks like they're kind of fish people
or I think they're beautiful Rama crowd
it sounds like to me like they're just
like the apocalypse or whatever actually
like mutated them or say so there's
still people there just like mutated in
people whatever they did that determine
and yeah and then at the end you don't
know if she's human or if she's one of
these animal people and then they leave
on that line which is actually like this
really deep line like do you think she
was human or
and avoid chicks like we're all wild
animals I'm like it's kinda cliche but
it's also kind of deep yeah and it's an
episode where it really kind of fits so
I really like this one I was like really
pulled in and I it's the first time
where it's like no now like really I
like the show and I want to keep seeing
more of it was the first time where I'm
like wow I really want to know what's
going on now like I'm really I'm really
fascinated welcome to the fold
ya know it's like it just took this one
episode but it's like something like
eight giant things were dropped in your
lap you're like whoa okay you didn't get
all the answers but it's like it's sort
of the start of it and yeah now it's
like yeah I really wanna know where it's
going or just where it went how it all
got to this point so yeah I'm really
fascinated now I just really liked when
they go down there initially and they're
looking around in Jake it's like we can
rule them like gods his delivery was so
good too angry god this I also like the
voice actors doing Finn you know it's
obvious his voice is getting deeper but
it's like he's working with it really
well or it did work with this you know
pretty old now but yeah and like there's
one part where Jake turns himself into a
couch and Finn sits down and says it's
just like come on like that and I don't
think that would have been as funny if
you had the higher pitched voice I think
the PGS that was really good so it's
it's one of those things where it's like
because that's always the big concern
what's gonna happen when the child actor
our actors grows up and the voice
changes and stuff and uh they see the
work with it pretty well yeah I thought
it was just a fun episode I wouldn't say
it's one that really got me hooked right
away because I kind of was guessing that
they weren't gonna be human and it's
like oh damn they're not that kind of
sucks but yeah with Susan you still
don't know she never took off her hood
you didn't know that I just like when
she started eating like the candy and
was a psycho
or actually one of my favorite lines is
where she's rolling in the grass
well first you face plants yeah walk in
here and then he fynbos up is like oh
you got some grass blood on you they
probably know the glass could be like
knowing this plays it could have like
little faces make a talk everyone I
never know actually poorgrass come to
think of it we're monsters no we don't
live anew oh okay
Laura fine go mow your lawns people it's
okay but what if the happening was right
and the plants are alive and trying to
kill us then they're doing a very poor
job that's true I think they can do
better um considering all the venomous
and destructive and violence that plants
could possibly cause yeah they're pretty
low on the totem pole in terms of
killing people yeah I mean honestly it's
almost like Shyamalan didn't make a good
movie
did he ever there's that one where Bruce
Willis was a superhero now that's not to
know there is no good movie he ever made
especially one with Bruce Willis yeah I
do agree actually that's a yeah well so
uh yeah I I really like this one I get
really pulled in and yeah any closing
thoughts I did like when people's is
talking too fast you just gonna comment
from now on yeah people's is talking to
Finn about you know memories of humans
and he's like yeah when that happens
I've never met one and I get all OH
and he just like his eyes get big and he
gets like all like kind of like
depressed and sad and he's just like and
then later on you know a few seconds
later Jake snaps about and she's about
to say the same thing again she catches
herself and I know you and Jory have
been saying like how much kind of a
bitch she is and all that stuff I don't
have a problem I'm just okay I see I
kind of see it there that it's not
really that she's a bitch he just
doesn't know how to handle herself in
all situations you know she's too
wrapped up in the side
that she forgets about human emotion I
well is that one when she went really
crazy with like the Ice King or whatever
it was it the Ice King was that the one
we're alike but no we're like you're
here for there's something to do k yet
knows a do cannot see how that was the
one yeah
now he's pretty crazy yeah but I think
if that happened to most women even a
man they probably miss everything to me
and I'm not going that nuts yeah but it
wasn't done by someone else it's done by
God well then yell at him I have C and
you you pull the people's it's done no
good say that's not done
you still look beautiful yes thank you
you look sexy in your new shirt thank
you wait a minute but that's the same
shit from last night yeah